a report has been published finding that
a culture of bullying at one of
England's biggest NHS trusts could put
patients Care at risks it's all part of
a inquiry into serious bullying
allegations at University Hospitals
Birmingham NHS trust following claims
that Junior doctors were threatened if
they raised safety concerns well the
lead reviewer of the report said he was
disturbed by the consistent reporting of
bullying at the NHS Trust
the report said that any continuance of
a staff culture that corrosively affects
morale will put patient care at risk
the report also said that the trust is
very reluctant to accept criticism
and it makes 17 recommendations for
improvement across clinical safety
governance and Leadership staff welfare
and culture our correspondent Becky
Johnson joins us from Birmingham this is
a damning report Becky
this is a damning report into University
Hospitals Birmingham one of the biggest
providers of healthcare not just in
England but in Europe employing more
than 22 000 people the report has found
a long-standing bullying and toxic
environment within this NHS trust it's
revealed extensive complaints have been
made by staff about the organization's
conduct many concerned about a toxic
atmosphere and bullying at all levels of
management it said the report team has
heard many examples on a range of topics
including issues over promotion bullying
of Staff including Junior doctors and
Affair of Retribution if concerns were
raised indeed one survey found only just
over half of staff at this trust felt
safe to raise concerns with managers now
concerningly for patients the reporters
highlighted are higher than would be
expected mortality rate in other words
more patients dying at this trust than
would be expected and the report says
more investigation needs to be done to
understand why that is happening but the
report says if the cultural environment
at uhb has not already affected
mortality it is likely to be affecting
the patient experience and morbidity
effective teamworking leads to higher
levels of innovation and a culture of
openness has been shown to reduce
mortality lower recruitment levels both
medical and nursing are associated with
increased mortality and worse patient
outcome and if the staff's current
concerns about the working environment
have not already translated to less good
treatment and outcome every shred of
evidence suggests they will do in time
so a damning assessment suggesting that
the report's authors believe that the
culture the way staff are treated here
is now affecting patient care at this
West Midlands trust now it found that as
of November last year over thirteen
percent of nursing posts that the trust
were unfilled that's higher than the
England average of 10 and suggests that
problems with recruitment are because of
the culture at the trust it also uh
detailed the very tragic events around
the death by Suicide of a junior doctor
Dr vaish Kumar last summer Dr Kumar was
35 years old she was working here at the
Queen Elizabeth Hospital in Birmingham
she took a lethal overdose and we've
spoken to her parents who say that she
left a note to them saying that she did
what she did because of what was going
on at work they say that she had become
very tearful from being a bubbly
fun-loving woman she'd become very
tearful after working here had spoken
about bullying had spoken about being
belittled and laughed at at work and
they'd seen her spiral into depression
now the report says that the way the
hospital management dealt with Dr
Kumar's death left many Junior doctors
very angry they say that there wasn't
Senior Management representation at her
funeral in fact the trust didn't contact
her family until two months after her
death shockingly 26 days after her death
a member of Senior Management at the
hospital who didn't know she died
emailed her personally to ask why she'd
been removed from her post and if she
was still being paid and the report
found that her death wasn't the only
death by Suicide of a member of staff at
this trust now we've been speaking to Dr
Kumar's father who is also a doctor who
works for the NHS and this is what he
had to say about the improvements needed
at this trust
our life stopped on 22nd of June
and it's very hard to each day is a
struggle
now my main worry is to stop it
happening to others
and that is why
I want to bring this forward
so that people realize that there is a
toxic atmosphere
foreign
Ed a statement in response to this
report this is from the chief executive
of University Hospitals Birmingham
Jonathan Brotherton now he says patients
can continue to be confident that the
care and treatment provided at our
hospitals is safe we are pleased that
Professor Buick's overall view that's
the report author is that the trust is a
safe place to receive care he goes on to
say we fully accept his recommendations
and welcome the additional assurance
that has been asked for through further
independent oversight there are a number
of significant concerns that we need to
and have started to address we will
continue to learn from the past as we
move forward the statement goes on so we
want to develop a positive inclusive
work environment where people want to
come to work in a place that they're
proud to work in to do their very best
for our patients while we will not be
able to fix things as quickly as I would
we do need to do it as quickly as
possible for the benefit of patients and
staff who goes on to say I am committed
to ensuring this happens as we must now
focus on continuing to provide the best
possible patient care building a
values-led culture and supporting our
incredible colleagues so that the
response from the chief executive of
this trust after review found a culture
of bullying could now be affecting
patient safety